Cảnh sát bắt thang dài chú của ông Mắc Kẹ trong nhà năm tầng trái gần câu thi ngẹ.
Quảng chính rời sáng 2, là buông lên tại căn nhà dọc đình bệnh mấy mết quân,
một chét vũ lầu trên đường mũ tất tổ, vường thịt biệt đây.
Mắc tiền căn nhà tin răng tự tụi tây, khi đó trong nhà có năm người,
muốn người ở các tần dưới kịp hát ra ngoài,
dương của ông tảm với 2 tuổi Mắc Kẹ tưởng tượng gợp khi đàn thưới cây.
Khói đàn nhìn chóng bao dùng các tần trên chiến việc tiếp tận khó khăn.
Cảnh sát phòng trái trái trái điều xa phương dụt từ nhiều chiến sĩ đến dịch trường.
Liao lên mả nhà bên cạnh, đối 2 thang dông tiếp tận tình năm và đưa nạn nhân xuống ăn toàn.
Đám trái được khủng trái sau khoảng 4 vút, vù trái thêu dụt nhiều tài sản,
buình nhân đang được nhiều trái.